holy [ __ ] [ __ ] you guys says we have
an excellent connection i don't know
what the problem oh yeah but like i said
it said that the last two or three times
so wait for everybody to come in i still
don't have a uh
this is making me so mad this is making
me i don't have a notification that the
stream
started yet i mean this happened on the
jonestown show too
but normally we don't have this much
problem it's like
it just keeps cutting out it's not us
it's either youtube or google i think
because it's been [ __ ] with me too
and mostly
youtube on my other on my mobile devices
youtube doesn't work as well as it used
to anymore
i mean my shit's always slow so i don't
really know
might be your internet upload speed it
might be i don't know
i don't usually have this much problem
honestly before
i didn't have any problem until right
about maybe the jonestown show or maybe
a
time or two before when it would like
it's the government it's a government
i'm sure it's not okay
all right let's see what everybody's
saying third time's a charm or oracle
says that
our fifth time or how are many [ __ ]
fingers crosses that's what
shea nicole is saying i'm gonna have to
do so much
louise
it just makes me want to know we got a
good connection senator it says says
our speed is excellent our connections
well it says that now
we'll see yeah and it says tom is the
fbi that's what shea nicole said
yeah fbi is watching me oh now i get
error again now you got error again yep
i wonder what the hell that is it says
open widget
yeah i did that already it really
doesn't help how's that all about
youtube is not receiving enough videos
yeah that's what i got last time
there's such a views hold on but the
stream is healthy
yeah that doesn't make sense yeah it
says poor connection
but that's what it did last time yeah
scroll
up scroll down so i can see no data
youtube is not currently receiving data
for
for this stream but it is
that's some weird [ __ ] viewers will
experience buffering
i wonder if there's anything else we can
do i don't know we restarted the wi-fi
like a couple of times right that didn't
seem to make a difference
i have no idea and everything victor
gave us five dollars says put it in
right put it in rice
i don't know can we just like we'll just
talk about it let's just [ __ ] run
with it
it's like if we have to keep restarting
it i'm just gonna
keep getting progressively angrier and
angrier
yeah until at the end i'm just going to
be like oh
i'm just going to [ __ ] you know where
will i know you don't want to hear it
but it could be
that because of the topic they've got us
[ __ ] throttled there's no way of
knowing
they may not want to be taught and it's
just ai it may not be a living person
doing this to us
title the next segment puppy power yeah
yeah yeah that's a good idea my dude
[Laughter]
i'll call it completely inoffensive
topic
maybe i should start calling oliver [ __ ]
that yeah that would be really funny
um yeah but like i said i feel like
we've done like worse [ __ ] than this and
like no one cared about that
this is critical of the federal
government yeah but a lot of our [ __ ] is
fun
things have changed i don't know
drunk knitting
[Laughter]
oh my god i love the [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
so
you guys need me there to fix this [ __ ]
right yeah i probably do i don't i don't
i don't really see what the problem
could be
i don't know it's just i don't know i
don't know
i'm just like i'm not worrying about it
we did
okay for a long time last time before it
[ __ ] out on me yeah so
all right keeping up with the davidians
so can we talk about the [ __ ] let's
talk about waco i just want to get
through all this [ __ ] before
it starts crashing on me again so as i
said
uh if you weren't here last time they
had a resurrection contest
which i mean
that's a pretty awesome way to like
[ __ ]
hey who's gonna run my cult who can
bring this dead body back from the dead
like i said i'm not sure how fresh she
was
um but you know that would have been
impressive admittedly
um but obviously neither of them did it
which should come as a surprise to no
one
um so uh yeah so there was a gun fight
the koresh people got charged with
attempted murder they all kind of got
off
um david koresh was kind of held longer
but it ended in a mistrial so he also
ended up getting off
now in 1989 um
george rhoden uh who was
you know the the dude that had thrown
down
the corpse resurrection challenge he
actually ended up
axing a dude to death so like i said
these are not stable individuals that
we're talking about
he acts to do to death uh the dude was
named
weymondale adair because
maybe he was bad no well he asked him
because
weymon said that he was the true messiah
oh yeah that's bad so he was trying so
he killed him with an axe yeah he's like
oh you're trying to claim the [ __ ]
throne of god [ __ ] you [ __ ]
so george was a little sensitive yeah
about other people saying they were the
messiah
the lord's name in vain clearly yeah and
he's like yeah well you say
you're i know i'm the messiah you say
you're the messiah i'm gonna kill a
[ __ ] and he was
clearly um very ready to do that you
know what i mean
he said he was a witch and [ __ ]
you're not gonna be these false messiahs
around me i'm gonna restore the order of
god
you gotta watch it around [ __ ] you
know some of these people that are
that take religion so seriously that
they think that they can
reanimate the dead that's some serious
[ __ ] man
that's what i mean these people just you
need to back away slowly just
back away slowly well i understand it i
totally understand it
oh listen to [ __ ] roger price myth
vision podcast you guys check that [ __ ]
out
it's a [ __ ] great podcast
you just you're gonna run into some
people that
you know every now and then that really
believe this stuff
and they think that they're in a bible
story yep because
they believe it so much that therefore
they're front and center
they're a [ __ ] bible character in
their own new chapter
of the [ __ ] new testament it's the
new new testament
and and that's not i'm in the center of
that yeah and that's not the only time
that's happened that's happened a lot
that's how religions start there's
always that one [ __ ] and when you
think that god's watching you
has put you on the earth to [ __ ] make
a new covenant
and it's all lining up and you're making
a connection between what you're doing
and what's happening in the new
testament in the old testament
hitting somebody with an axe for acting
bad that's not
that's not that far you know what i mean
that's not too far out of the pail i
kind of feel like the trouble starts
no matter what it is whether it's
religion or whatever
the trouble starts when you start
feeling that one you are special
and that two because you are special
you're allowed to tell other people what
they can do
well the religion is not for you because
that's
well i figured that out when i was 11.
that's what religion is all about
yeah again religion is all about why
that's why religion is not for me
you are not special yeah no one is
special and i'm not picking on
christianity
at all all of them are like they don't
like that
well i get it i get the need to believe
it's like we're special like
you know it's very human to want to be
in a group and like everyone else sucks
and it's like you guys are the outsiders
we're the insiders we have the special
knowledge we're
gonna be raptured or whatever the [ __ ]
the belief system is
but i think it's much more healthy to
just believe that it's like hey
i'm not special i'm just a [ __ ]
like every other [ __ ] and it's
like
the second you start believing you're
the messiah or you're kind of like yeah
that's
that's when the trouble starts yeah but
right now i don't think really i don't
think chris
christians are the are the issue i think
the ones that are the
the main ones you got to watch for
actually scientology
scientology is that same exact thing
well that's what i mean
anything like that is a dangerous
mindset
the second you start thinking i'm
special
i know things that other people don't
know and i know things that other people
don't know i'm better than other people
scientology is above the government
right right right and
the second you start thinking that then
that is when
the danger starts yeah the american
government is
totally [ __ ] up and the laws of
[ __ ] scientology supersede the laws
of the government
they don't have any authority over you
and at any day l ron hubbard could
return
i mean they literally believe that they
built i keep telling him i told him this
last night actually
i was like you should totally go into
a scientology center someplace because
they're all over
and you should say that you're the
reincarnation like that you're back
of lrh of lrh you could do the lip thing
well yeah it would take a while
it would be a good grip though yeah you
might be able to get a lot of money out
of those idiots
they wouldn't buy it because miscavige
is a grifter he knows none of it's true
um gotta be uh the the
the thing about the thing about
scientology
is that everything i've studied about
scientology i wish it was true
why
[Laughter]
look at her no no
that would be awesome if you could
develop [ __ ] psychic powers
sure but you know reverse time and
[ __ ] you know i mean
live forever and uh be able to [ __ ]
do ever
do things that scientologists want to do
and that it's it's this [ __ ] great
organization that
that's going to fix the world and it's
kind of like taking over the world and
it's growing exponentially
that would be cool if that was true it's
not true no but if it was true that
would be kind of cool that'd be kind of
like basically you're talking about the
jedi
that's what you're talking about it'd be
very cool but
lrh wasn't that great of a [ __ ]
sci-fi writer and
when you see videos of him and he they
liked him but
nah he seemed a little creepy and weird
he knew he understood well he
he knew how to he understood that making
a [ __ ] a wizard is a [ __ ]
great grift he built an empire who am i
to [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] or talk [ __ ] about him
that dude [ __ ] built a huge empire
on making a [ __ ] wizard now well
he
was able to trade upon the stupidity of
others
oh they weren't stupid uh they were just
wanting to believe
and there's a lot of people yeah
stupidity is perhaps not the right word
stupidity is not because a lot of smart
people do get into cults it's not
necessarily
just yeah it's not necessarily i just
use that as like a shrine
that's like so i don't i don't want to
call scientologists stupid it's just
more a little bit gullible that want to
believe this stuff
um but you know when you look at
everything that they own all their
[ __ ] real estate and [ __ ] all the
buildings it'd be great in their own
little communities and bases and [ __ ]
if that worked and it was awesome i'd be
cool with that
but they're [ __ ] not doing they're
not treating their [ __ ] members too
well and they're not having a good time
we'll see and that's like i said what
but
i gotta say that's not the original way
scientology was was imagined
during the time of l ron hubbard people
liked the cult
and they liked l ron hubbard it wasn't a
[ __ ] see that's why i think you
should go back in there and say right
and straighten all that [ __ ] out
i'll say and maybe get us a few million
yeah
just you know nah never have you do it
no
it is a short man's empire you got [ __ ]
that's what i'm saying
you could really get in on that [ __ ]
[ __ ] me miss cabbage
and [ __ ] tom cruise we're going to
line up and see you're like simponica
with that you're like kind of the same
personality type is like
well i mean you're not as sociopathic
and evil as
it's like the short dude brotherhood
there's like a [ __ ] short yeah i'll
[ __ ]
come in here you can't fix it with those
guys
i don't really give a [ __ ] about fixing
scientology i just want some money
out of out of there's more to life than
money dummies there's more to life
power they're very well here's the thing
they're very willing
to take money from people so i really do
not feel bad about taking money from
them
yeah so if you five six 190 pounds
my [ __ ] said it disconnected or did you
guys get a thing
uh we're back yeah it said it
disconnected but now it's back on again
yeah
okay whatever it's just [ __ ] weird i
got a little message that said
disconnection
thing hiccup okay so there was a hickey
yeah yeah tila uh i asked you
answering your question i'm five six and
uh about 190 pounds
yeah i'm only five foot three yeah so
i'm even shorter than david
yeah i could punch him right in the dick
or step on it with my high heel shoes uh
but miss cabbage and
and tom cruise's claimed heights are not
what they claim dudes have a thing
they're very sensitive about how tall
they are
right so you know they always have to
like add a few they're adding a few
inches
they're [ __ ] putting those looking
lifts in their shoes and adding [ __ ]
shoe
lift height i think [ __ ] cruz claims
to be five
eight yep [ __ ] about five five
maybe five four i do not believe that
whatsoever no
and i think miss cabbage is about five
five because look at him next to nicole
kidman
who he was married to for a time she's
not
that tall i mean she's tall for a woman
but she's not
that tall and when she was standing next
to tom cruise when they were together
she he looked like way way shorter than
her yeah
tom cruise evidently wears uh special
buildings
but you know what dude if you're short
just be short
well he married tall women yeah they're
pretty tall
well or they're maybe around his height
or maybe a little bit tall but they when
then they wear heels
um but i do get you know a lot of people
don't like me [ __ ] defending tom
tom cruise um some people are saying
that i'm just
referring to myself why is he talking to
himself and
talking about himself in the first
person
all right tom um
tom [ __ ] you know he he's
considerably older than me he's in good
shape though he's not he's a good
looking guy
he's very athletic and um he's very
skilled you know some people was like oh
don't defend him he's an [ __ ]
how do we know he can do all this he he
owns aircraft he uh
rides motorcycles he's got real training
with small arms he's real good with guns
um and scientology is a paramilitary
organization
basically you know uh it's structured
the sea org is structured like the navy
and they're supposed to be kind of like
the spiritual
the spiritual [ __ ] navy seals of
[ __ ] l ron hubbard they're like the
jedi
that's what they're supposed to be they
were the jedi before the jedi
they're less fun than the jedi i feel
like yeah
they had psychic powers and they could
fight and they had [ __ ] ships and all
those other books
that's what the [ __ ] propaganda says
but really i think
if you were to actually look at what's
going on tom cruise probably had the
best of the scientology training and got
the best of the scientology
treatment the rest of them aren't
treated too well well obviously
he's a he's basically a god in
scientific he is well he's kind of like
there but
seriously and like i said i know we're
going way off topic but way out
what else is new um the scientologists
that i used to work at because like i
said you
work with i used to work in clearwater
and
some of them the older ones that were
like managers and stuff at the company
that i work for
had been to some of those big like
[ __ ] scientology shindigs like in
clearwater and some of them had met tom
cruise so some of them were like all
and they just could not stop drooling on
his dick
seriously it was like pathetic but
they were just like talking about how
awesome he was oh my god
it's tom cruise and he was like blah
blah blah but the thing about tom cruise
is that
he didn't have to do all the [ __ ] that
regular scientologists have to do no he
got the [ __ ]
because he's like they're he's a big
asset for them
yeah because i'm like a duke an archduke
well yeah because he's famous so he can
go out and like say hey
scientology is awesome and that's like a
really good that's why they [ __ ]
you know um that's why they opened all
these celebrity centers that's why they
like
you know ask his celebrities all this
time because they want that pr
yeah and he's one of miscavige's friends
he's personal friends with miss cabbage
miscavige runs that [ __ ] even though i
feel like scavenge just like
puts up with him evidently miscavige
sometimes
[ __ ] looks at him like he's a [ __ ]
douche yeah i mean i think they're
evidently they're like what a [ __ ]
deuce but
um i don't have proof of that that's
just what scientologists who've left the
church said
i think probably what it is is that
there are they have man crush on each
other
and they're constantly trying to [ __ ]
get in the water are they [ __ ] do you
think no
they're the [ __ ] tom's tom street
[ __ ] uh they're they're you a they're
in a dick competition
oh whose [ __ ] ot powers are greater
and who's
[ __ ] dudes tommy there's a lot of
i don't [ __ ] fully dismiss tom tom
tom is a [ __ ] good guy he's [ __ ]
kind of an anti-communist he's [ __ ]
believes all this stuff he kind of came
from nothing he's a bit of a bit of a
self-made man
um but he but tom has been described as
diabolical
and i got a special diabolical he's
diabolical
yeah leo yeah and um what they're
talking about
yeah i know exactly what she's talking
about that's the same thing that you see
in really hardcore army rangers they're
[ __ ] diabolical because they're elite
soldiers
and tom cruise sees himself as an elite
scientologist
so of course arrogant as [ __ ] you know
that's what
he's gonna but he's probably a kind of
guy that if you
talk to him on common grounds on certain
[ __ ] that he [ __ ] likes and you likes
and you're in the short guy club and you
ride motorcycles
and you shoot guns and you you talk bad
about [ __ ] commies
and [ __ ] then you like l ron hubbard
and [ __ ] he'd probably [ __ ]
like you he'd probably treat you well
but if you're
you'd make one wrong move he's going to
write you off you'll be like oh you're
eliminated [ __ ] out of here piece of
[ __ ]
and that's exactly the way i'm saying
that's where army rangers are
you fail [ __ ] out of here [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] you're a sub-human
that's exactly the the that's nice
you're nothing you know
well there's a hardcore ideology
if you don't fit that [ __ ] ideology
and that
and those abilities then you suck and
that's
and i'm not bullshitting go back and
[ __ ] study scientology
that is the ethos of scientology if
you are not an excellent scientology and
scientologist
you [ __ ] suck and that's that's the
that's the ethos of [ __ ] scientology
so if you are not a scientologist you
[ __ ] suck well done and like i said i
work for them i know
what their mindset is like that's why i
didn't like them because i'm like oh
yeah that's so cute you guys think
you're like [ __ ] special and stuff
yeah well they give they give that
arrogance to any random [ __ ]
in their ranks and there's not much to
most of these people just like buy
them out but tom has a lot of money and
he has a lot of experience so
i wouldn't i wouldn't consider tom to be
an average run-of-the-mill scientologist
well like i said he didn't he gets all
the best [ __ ]
[ __ ] they don't like treat him shitty
like they do the other scientologists
if you threw a [ __ ] pistol down to
tom and you threw it down to me we don't
have body armor and we're going through
a [ __ ] rubber room
to [ __ ] try to kill each other i
wouldn't [ __ ] think that tom would
i wouldn't think that i would over match
tom tom probably pretty good with a gun
everything i've been seeing he's very
good with a gun i disrespect him
you know what i'm talking about he
shoots a lot same thing with [ __ ]
okay
jenny doesn't know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about same thing with kenny
reeves kenu reeves is good with a gun
why do you always say i don't know what
are you talking about well you're not
you didn't look back at me and you're
just like going hey
well cause i'm trying to get back to the
waco [ __ ] we're gonna get back
um i've seen kenny reeves shoot at the
range
he's very good with a gun very good that
[ __ ] and john wick
that's not a realistic fire fight but he
can't make hits like that
i've seen him do it on [ __ ] steel
targets and man targets and [ __ ] he's
very good
um i wouldn't go up against [ __ ]
canoe reeves not
in in a room in a room to room
combat [ __ ] scenario i'm not polished
up for that i'd have to [ __ ] go in
for
a good four months and retrain and get
[ __ ] slick like back in the day
i was never really trained for that i
was trained for a vietnam type situation
which is ambush and counter ambush
you know that's which is lying in weight
that's what it's all about
but uh lying in weight and misery
so but no [ __ ]
those dudes are good with gods very good
tila says i wonder if there are more
celebs in scientology than we think
there are well
some science some celebrities that are
in scientology that disappointed me
i'm gonna tell you that right now um
elizabeth moth
moss um you guys she was an invisible
man she's in a handmaid's tale
um yeah she's a scientologist i'm sorry
if that bums you out um that bums me out
uh giovanni rubisi that one kind of bums
me out as well
there's more than that back is one um i
don't know if he's still in
um there's a few other ones but normally
like other than those
i feel like a lot of them are like kind
of d list
you know not to be an [ __ ] but i feel
like
carrie north says tom cruise is a
standard twitter social justice warrior
i i wouldn't believe anything [ __ ]
tom cruise actually says in public
he's uh according to everybody who knows
him
he has a public image and then he has a
real image
in reality he's [ __ ] diabolical all
right and people are talking about him
yelling at the crew of mission
impossible
that [ __ ] if you give him some
rules he's going to enforce those rules
on you he's a stickler
he's a stickler and and he's
i understand exactly what you guys were
talking about [ __ ] tom cruise that dude
would probably be difficult to be around
but i'm just saying obviously yeah it'd
probably be difficult to be i mean even
when i first saw him in [ __ ] risky
business i was like man i bet that
dude's a douche in real life
yeah yeah mango says beck is in loser
but yeah that back
yeah um he wasn't i don't know about
nowadays but i know that he was kind of
one of the ones that was touted as like
being a scientologist
yeah victor says that yeah tom's tom is
tom cruise is good with guns he's
talking about me and tom in a rubber
room
rubber room is a [ __ ] training
environment where it's a room made out
of damn tires
and you run through it and you use
simunition
or sometimes real ammunition to uh train
for room clearing that's what i mean by
rubber room
it's a range that you that looks like
rooms you shoot shoot through
all right so we can can we get back
today go ahead let's finish this [ __ ]
finally well yeah dude okay look at
where
look at where this thing is i have that
much
left to go on this it's like people want
to
want to go to the range three quarters
people want to go to the range i haven't
even got
i've got to write a quarter of my notes
okay and that's it
we're gonna go to the range i don't even
think we're gonna finish this [ __ ]
because we're probably
like [ __ ] yeah so like i said
george rhoden uh kills somebody with an
axe like you do
when you're in a cult you know so he
gets sent to
a psychiatric hospital because they were
like yeah you're bad [ __ ] insane
so they sent him to a psychiatric
hospital in big spring texas
now it so happened that because george
rhoden still owed a bunch of
unpaid taxes on the mount carmel center
which as i said was
that was the uh branch davidian you know
compound from like way back in the 30s
so we had a bunch of taxes on that so
david koresh decides to swoop in him and
his followers like hey
we'll pay the taxes on that like they
raise the money and we'll just
you know we'll take over the [ __ ] so
that's what he did
um because you know like i said the old
lady was dead
the son was in a mental institution
because he killed somebody with an axe
because wha this whole [ __ ] thing man
yeah so
so uh so yeah so they move back into the
mount carmel
property now george rhoden is still
trying to like you know get back into
his [ __ ]
he's like follow filing all these
[ __ ] legal
kind of [ __ ] and it's like you know and
it never really came to anything
now what they ended up doing though was
that david koresh was able to
apparently successfully argue that
whoever had been living in the mount
carmel premises
had uh started a meth lab which like i
said
not entirely surprising considering the
type of people that you're talking about
um so he kind of reported that to the
cops they moved that [ __ ] out and they
were like hey we're taking over the [ __ ]
now
so that's kind of like how that happened
so at this point david koresh
takes over this you know
branch davidian compound away from
the people that had owned it previously
now
let's talk a little bit about the child
abuse
and uh statutory rape allegations
now a lot of the [ __ ] and as i said
you know it's arguable but this is kind
of one of the first things that came
onto the radar of
federal authorities that some [ __ ] was
going on
after david karash took over that um
children were being abused or
you know statutory raped or whatever um
during his tenure at
the compound now
his thing was he started
as i said the house of david so he
proclaimed himself
a messiah i don't
know it's i don't know it's weird he
kind of said that
he didn't say he was jesus per se but he
kind of said that he was like
a personification of the second coming
of jesus you know what i mean that's why
he named himself david because it was
like house of david
so he wasn't saying that he was actual
jesus but he was like the second coming
of jesus
so basically what he said was that
god told me that i'm going to have
24 children by chosen women in the
community
and so he decided he was going to go
about that by basically saying to
everyone else that was in the sect
that okay well all of your wives and
daughters are essentially
fair game um it doesn't matter if you
are married to them it doesn't matter
like i have
full control over them like god told me
that i could father children with your
wives and your daughters and there's
nothing you could say about it and you
are not allowed to have sex with them
anymore ain't that some [ __ ] which
that's some [ __ ] there
like i said that's some stan that's your
standard that's the rest right out of
[ __ ] brigham young and
that's your job no john smith yeah in
the mormon
church oh by the way your wife is now my
wife
oh and your your your daughter she's
mine too
yeah yeah so anybody that's feeling any
sympathy for david koresh
don't because uh he actually did believe
this and a bunch of people did
sadly go along with this [ __ ] yeah and
some of these daughters that we're
talking about wild sex
we're like 12. yeah okay it's fetish
stuff
and the dads like signed them away
because
you know even in texas at that point
it's like look you have to be at least
16 unless you get legally married
so you had to have parental permission
so when david koresh said well god told
me that i could marry all of your wives
and daughters
some of the dads and the cult were like
okay fine i'll sign over my 12 year old
or 14 year old daughter
yeah it's religious cuckery [ __ ] off
with that
so like i said you videotape it you make
dead watch and then you [ __ ] sell the
videos online kind of like you know what
i wouldn't put that
song yeah i really wouldn't that's like
some [ __ ] [ __ ] from that movie about
the karate [ __ ] guys what was it
i wouldn't beat people up so like i said
i don't have any sympathy for like the
atf or the fbi in this situation but i
really don't have any sympathy for
koresh or any of that kind of [ __ ] going
on because seriously
some dude comes to you and says
hey god told me that i could have kids
with your wife and you can't have sex
with her anymore
and like a dude that'd be like okay fine
yeah but look
i don't think anybody has any has any uh
sympathy for koresh i don't
dude's a dick very deluded i think he
believed it but he's very deluded
and like i said everyone is bad guys in
that situation what i feel bad about is
what happened to his church
because those people were under the
control of mind control yeah that's the
only people i feel bad for the women and
children
that died all this [ __ ] could have been
avoided had they just
gone down to town and waited for korres
to show up to buy supplies and they
could have arrested him there
and that would have that would have
[ __ ]
probably solved the problem and you
didn't even need to give the dude a
whole lot of time
i think if he [ __ ] scared the [ __ ]
out of him and given a few months it
probably would have straightened him out
he's kind of nutty dude what kind of
dude was nutty
um big time yeah dude like i said if you
listen to any of these
videos or any of the sermons that he
gave which they did record
he's delusional he just sounds like a
lunatic
oh [ __ ] man [ __ ] look it's it on mine
it's
[ __ ] installed but it might just be
my advice yeah it might just be it's
just my device my [ __ ] still says
excellent so
i'm just going to keep going we got an
excellent connection it says
dan says i'd love to have seen some
dudes say when my daughter was 12 i'm
going to take your daughter as my wife
it's like they've ended up buried in the
middle of nowhere right
it's like and i feel like most normal
people would have that same reaction
this is not
some [ __ ] out of the blue though this
was real common behavior
in christian cults well they can
they can say that it's in the bible
because it is
it is and then they can kind of twist it
and especially if they've added kind of
a
uh like a paranormal or a uh
what's a good word to use kind of like
uh
spiritism you know you know spiritualism
like they had a lot of gnostic stuff
going on it was like spiritism
in uh in mormonism in the early morning
it still is that way
and that was kind of going on in
koresha's church too
and once you start having that angle
you can twist scripture around to mean
all kinds of [ __ ]
well and i wanted to bring that up
because apparently someone asked him
once it's like where did you get this
idea that
you could basically have sex with other
people's wives and yada yada and other
people's daughters and whatnot
and he said allegedly that what he came
up with
was that he pointed to this one biblical
verse that said something about
you know the king like his head is
anointed with oil or whatever
and he was able to spin that into oh
well they meant head like a penis and
anointed
means like vag juice damn that's
essentially what he said so like i said
this is the dude that we're
dealing with here what'd you think about
that t this is the dude that we're
dealing with
that's how he rationalized yeah
he's like well the bible says that i can
hit whoever i want and you can't do
anything about it
so you know special that's the kind of
[ __ ] though that was in the early
mormons though
especially that same kind of same kind
of thing right but it's still
fun to get your wife because it's not a
real marriage it's a celestial marriage
and that's happening yeah god said it
was space and it's you know i mean and
that's
if you if i marry your wife then she
will have [ __ ] children that will go
on to to become
gods and create their own universes and
everything
yeah that's essentially what he argued
and that's why a lot of the husbands
were
apparently i'm not sure if they were
entirely okay with it but they
let it happen if i hit they let it
happen that's what they're gonna do
i'm gonna make your woman a goddess if
you let me hit that's [ __ ] what what
what they're talking about
but apparently allegedly he would not
let the husbands have sex with their
wives you know
he was gonna shut that [ __ ] off man
because he had to make sure that
the seed that the seed was stemming from
the [ __ ] true messiah
david karesh that's what they're talking
about yep that's exactly what he was
doing i understand it
so like i said